sie sagen diese Schleuser werden immer
dreister es wird immer verroter es wird
immer brutaler und es wird auch immer
professioneller und ich habe das von
zitiert sie sagen es gibt sogenannte
garantieschleusungen mittlerweile aus
der Türkei was ist das das finde ich nur
aus der Türkei also garantieschleusungen
gibt es ja schon sozusagen ewigen Zeiten
das heißt also wenn ich nach Deutschland
einreisen will gibt es ja mittlerweile
sogar einen Markt im Internet wo ich
mich melden kann sozusagen in arabischer
Sprache oder in den Sprachen wo die
herkommen kann ich mich melden ich
möchte nach Deutschland wie komme ich
dahin und dann wird dann bezahlt das
läuft dann ganz einfach übers Internet
und dann kann ich eben auch fliegen
mittlerweile Belarus und Moskau moskau
ist ja so die Fluglinie im Moment und
das hatten wir ja alles schon mal mit
der Belarus Linie da ist ja auch dann
mal gestoppt worden in dem man gesagt
hat okay gewisse Fluglinien dürfen nicht
mehr nach Europa rein und sowas das sind
Sachen die müssten mittlerweile jetzt
auch wieder passieren passiert aber
nicht macht aber nichts an der Tatsache
diese garantieschleusung sagen die
kommen zu uns an die Grenze
ich werde eben vielleicht nicht
rübergebracht oder wie auch immer und
irgendwie schaffen sie es dann eben
trotzdem nach Deutschland zu kommen weil
der Schleuser sagt wenn ich es heute
nicht so klappt dann mache ich das
morgen mal und wir kriegen sie auf jeden
Fall nach Deutschland und was bleibt uns
anderes übrig Frau Röhrl hat es eben
schon gesagt wenn derjenige ein Schutz
ersuchen stellt also Asylantrag oder
Asyl sagt wenn wir in aufgreifen bleibt
uns nichts anderes übrig als ihn
mitzunehmen zu bearbeiten und
weiterzuleiten an das Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge an die
Zentrale Aufnahmestelle das ist leider
so und deswegen ist es auch falsch zu
sagen ich brauche stationäre statische
Grenzkontrollen wie als Gewerkschaft der
Polizei sagen das ist fehlerhaft weil
wir suggerieren der Bevölkerung derzeit
wir haben einen Schlagbaum hallo du
bleibst jetzt draußen das geht einfach
nicht die wenigsten die nach Deutschland
kommen zumindest im polnischen Bereich
ist es so ich sag mal 90 95% sagen Asyl
und dementsprechend muss ich sie
aufnehmen ich kann nicht am Schlagbaum
sagen so hallo du bleibst jetzt draußen
das geht nicht und das was derzeit
politisch gesagt wird ist eben der
Bevölkerung zu suggerieren wir machen
die Schlagbäume zu machen stationäre
Grenzkontrollen und dann kommt keiner
mehr rein das ist fehlerhaft und ist
auch nicht richtig und die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen vor Ort Herr Lanz wenn sie
ich lade Sie gerne mal ein dahin nach
Forst zum Beispiel Dienststelle und das
was die Kollegin da sehen tagtäglich sie
sehen es ja auch im Einspieler hier
kinderfamilien Kleinstkinder und Babys
in Transportern wo sie mit 40 Leuten
eingefärbt hinten drin sind keine Luft
mehr kriegen und die Kollegen und
Kollegen sehen das tagtäglich die sind
am Limit die sind über dem Limit und was
bei uns und das ist gerade auch so eine
Richtung ähm Herr Buschmann hat das
gesagt man muss ja auch im Bereich der
Justiz was machen also was man bei uns
bei der Bundespolizei wirklich
fehlerhaft die letzten Jahre nicht
gemacht hat ist die aus und
Fortbildungen im Bereich der
ermittlungsdienste und im
kriminaltechnischen Bereich da ist
fehlerhaft nichts passiert im
Bundespolizei Präsidium das muss sich
das Bundespolizeipräsidium wirklich
antreiben und wenn Sie jetzt den
Einspieler sehen jetzt sehen sie
natürlich junge Männer aber es sind
nicht nur junge Männer die da kommen
jetzt sehen sie auch Frauen und Kinder
und das ist das was die was die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wirklich greift
derzeit und wir haben das gerade gesehen
riesen Aufgebot dann wird er dieser
kleinen Transporter angehalten und so
weiter sie sagen die Leute werden
überall versteckt das passiert auf
kriminellste Art und Weise zum Teil
stimmt es dass es soweit so weit geht
das der Schleuser in auf den letzten
Metern einfach aus dem Auto springt und
das Auto einfach auf die deutsche
Polizei suchen genau auch das ist schon
passiert der Wagen sollte Anhalten der
Wagen ist einfach weiter gerollt und der
Schleuser ist aus dem Auto gesprungen
und hat sich versucht der Festnahme zu
entziehen man hat ihn aber gekriegt aber
das sind solche Sachen wo ich sage das
geht gar nicht mehr so aber das machen
jetzt das Auto an
und stelle es fest da sind Leute was ist
das was wir hier das dürfte den
Schleuser sein der versucht gerade
auf der Flucht vor der Polizei
gefährlich
ist und jetzt sehen sie ja wie viele
Leute da hinten drin sitzen oder stehen
die nicht wissen die können nicht
rausgucken gar nichts die nicht wissen
was passiert
und wie gesagt und das ist nicht nur der
polnische Bereich oder tschechische
Bereich hier Bayern sondern ist auch
unten zu Österreich und zwar Schweiz die
komplette Grenze haben wir da unten auch
und jetzt sage ich ihnen wir haben auch
da unten statische Kontrollen und
trotzdem hat die Grenzpolizei aus Bayern
riesen Aufgriffe das heißt also diese
statischen Kontrollen sind nicht der
richtige Weg sondern so wie wir das
Sagen flexible Kontrollen und nicht
statisch sie wollen keine
Straßenkontrollen treffen
Schleierfahndung sowie Frau Walter sagt
anders kriegen wir das nicht und anders
ist es auch nicht händelbar ja wir sind
mit dem Personal am Limit das verstehe
ich aber nochmal frage ich will noch mal
den Modus verstehen dass er wirklich
interessant also sie setzen die Polizei
ein sie halten den an
dann machen sie die Tür auf dann sitzen
diese ganzen armen Menschen drin
teilweise mit viel zu wenig Luft
teilweise katastrophale hygienische
Zustände und so weiter
was passiert dann was ist die Konsequenz
sie halten den an und dann was die
Konsequenz ist der Schleuse der Mitte
und bringen Sie wohin die werden mit zur
Dienststelle genommen werden
abgearbeitet sozusagen da so spricht man
davon sie wird ja auch eine Strafanzeige
erstmal gestellt obwohl wenn sie Asyl
beantragen ist die Strafanzeige ja
normalerweise dann noch hinfällig macht
aber nichts an der Tatsache sie bekommen
dann einen eine anlaufbescheinigung und
gehen dann zur zentralen Aufnahmestelle
bei uns in brandenburgisches
Eisenhüttenstadt da werden sie dann
hingebracht oder wenn sie Geld haben
wird dann gesagt da vorne ist eine Taxi
oder ist auch ein Zug und dann fahren
sie dahin das heißt sie greifen die
Leute ein und bringen sie dann zur
Annahmestelle genau
für den Schleuser gilt das allerdings
nicht ja natürlich
aber das heißt im Grunde geht es nur
darum irgendwie die deutsche Grenze oder
die deutsche Polizei zu erreichen das
hat keiner Unterschied die rufen ja
Konsequenz nein sie rufen auch an wenn
sie auf deutschen Hoheitsgebiet sind
entweder man geht zu einem Bürger und
sagt rufen Sie mal die Polizei das ist
ja Gang und Gäbe mittlerweile und die
Bürger melden sich mittlerweile auch bei
der Polizei und dann wird er hingefahren
und werden abgeholt du versuchst illegal
in ein Land zu kommen
ja du wirst erwischt
und es hat keine Konsequenz nein
weil es so viele legale Methoden nicht
gibt verstehen
Asylantrag vorliegt insofern ist das
illegale Migration ist ja immer ein
bisschen komisch gefärbt weil diese
diese sehr unmenschliche Situation in
diesen LKWs die ist eigentlich das
Produkt von einer falschen Politik weil
ich dachte das ist doch der Berliner
kaputtes System klar aber in dem Moment
wo man sagt
illegale Migration das schiebt man die
Schuld sofort in Richtung von den
geflüchteten und die konnte nicht meine
absichtlich ich glaube es geht um die
Frage ob das System funktioniert sie
haben recht wenn alle Grenze also wir
haben ja in Europa die Errungenschaft
dass wir im Schengen Raum offene Grenzen
haben aber dann brauche ich halt starke
Außengrenze wenn ich die Außengrenze
ich sehe als der Schengen Raum gegründet
wurde steht da sogar drin absolut also
wir schaffen die binnen europäischen
Grenzen ab und dafür sicher mal im
Gegenteil die Außengrenzen umso besser
und das ist das Ergebnis genau und das
ist doch der der Punkt wir werden
das die Herausforderung dass wir ein
robusten außengrenzschutz brauchen die
werden wir nie mit
Binnengrenzkontrollen kompensieren
können weil sich sonst die Polizisten
ich sag mal entschuldigung darf man den
Arsch abarbeiten oder am Limit arbeiten
sondern es ist doch es ist doch die
frustrierendste aber die haben mir
vorstellen kann
sondern die wissen auch nicht mehr wie
dieses bearbeiten soll das muss sagen
uniformiertes Begrüßungskomitee oder er
sagt das edeltaxi für asylbe jetzt will
ich mal fragen die Politik also ich kann
meine Hand dafür verlegen das aus meiner
Partei den Polizisten niemals jemand
sowas sagen wird
und die machen ihre Arbeit und ihren Job
und auf deren Rücken darf man diese
Debatte nicht führen sondern das ist
doch der Grund dass wir es gar nicht
schaffen an den Binnengrenzen zu
kompensieren was ein fehlender robuster
außengrenzschutz
leisten könnte leisten müsste das ist
den Defekt an dem wir doch arbeiten das
ist diese geasreform über die jetzt alle
immer sprechen und wo wir froh sind dass
wir jetzt als Bundesregierung nicht 7
Jahren nicht wissen ob wir das gut für
den 3 Jahren greift man das stimmt aber
Herr lands es wäre doch schlimm wenn sie
nicht in drei Jahren wäre und in der
Zwischenzeit müssen wir uns natürlich
auch weiterhelfen das behauptet ja
keiner dass wir in der Zwischenzeit
nicht zu tun hätten ich habe ja auch ein
paar Ideen genannt aber es muss kommen
weil sonst diese Situation so
weiterlaufen wird und das darf nicht
sein da haben sie natürlich recht Frau
höher wie ist das bei Ihnen im Land
erst vor kurzem ist bei unserer Schleuse
aufgegriffen
vollgestopft mit Menschen die dann in
der Landschaft drum geirrt sind
irgendwann noch von aufgefallen sein und
der hat dann die Polizei gerufen aber
ich hätte eine Frage wenn wir darüber
sprechen dass an diesen EU-Außengrenzen
möglichst oder sogar auf afrikanischem
Gebiet auf ausländischem Gebiet diese
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen
die ersten Asylverfahren abgearbeitet
werden existieren dann müsste eigentlich
um das den Schleusern und das sehr
schnell rundum auch die geflüchteten
haben sehr gute Connections per Internet
zu kommen denn du wirst per Polizei
sofort zurückgefallen diese Lager die wo
auch immer errichtet werden
also nicht die Behandlung in der
Polizeistation nicht die Aufnahme in der
sondern in dieses
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung wie auch immer
ich habe ich hatte das
nämlich ein ein sachlichen Hinweis noch
geben weil sich jetzt Zuschauer bestimmt
die Frage stellen ist die deutsche
Politik eigentlich so doof warum macht
man kein Gesetz
dass die
Bundespolizei oder wer auch immer sagen
kann du kommst hier nicht rein das ist
eben europäisches Recht der Europäische
Gerichtshof hat entschieden wir dürfen
an den deutschen Grenzen nicht einfach
zurückweisen
sind Teil von Europa
auch relativ offen dass sie sich um
bestimmte Elemente des europäischen
Rechts nicht zu 100%ig kümmern das
gehört auch so ein bisschen ich war sehr
dafür dass wir aus diesem dänischen
Konzept auch was lernen ich finde man
sollte auch nicht überall sofort immer
denkt Verbote ausstellen oder sie als
Justizminister ein Hinweis auf die
rechte Seite vielleicht aber was sie
privat denken habe ich jetzt auch
gespürt sozusagen das ist ja ganz
interessant das nehme ich der Punkt die
Diskussion mal gerne auf eine
übergeordnete Ebene ziehen weil wir ja
diese Problematik nicht nur im
migrationskontext haben wo sehr viele
Menschen drunter leiden viele
geflüchtete
offensichtlich auch die Polizei und
viele andere Menschen in Grenzgebieten
das kann ich alles nachvollziehen aber
ganz grundsätzlich haben wir jetzt im 21
Jahrhundert eine Vielzahl von Krisen vor
uns und wir haben noch immer eine viel
zu langsame Reaktionsfähigkeit des
Staates ganz viele Probleme von denen
wir heute gesprochen haben die hängen
unmittelbar damit zusammen dass diese
bürokratischen Prozesse unglaublich
lange dauern extrem schwer
vorherbrechenbar sind und 100.000
verschiedene Winkel haben wo man
überhaupt nicht mehr weiß was man genau
tun kann und die allermeisten Leute
steigen überhaupt nicht dadurch ganz zu
schweigen von denen die kein Deutsch
sprechen insofern würde ich sagen wir
müssen eigentlich ganz grundsätzlich in
einem so beschleunigten jahrhundert wie
unser an einer sehr viel schnelleren
Reaktion die Fähigkeit des Staates
arbeiten denn daran hapert es ganz
extrem also da bin ich ganz ihrer
Meinung insbesondere für die Migration
die wir ja wollen also Leute die eine
Qualifikation haben in Deutschland gerne
arbeiten wollen das sind wir noch viel
zu langsam viel zu Papier getrieben ich
habe neulich bei einem Bekannten gesehen
der hat sich Neuseeland ein Visum über
eine App besorgt der hat seinen
Personalausweis fotografiert sein
Arbeitsvertrag fotografieren und hatte
da ein paar Minuten später
arbeiten das ist in der Vergangenheit so
gewesen dass man tatsächlich im Ausland
dann zu einem Konsulat hingehen musste
und dann wurde mit Stempel und Papier
und so weiter gearbeitet und deshalb
wollen wir jetzt im Bundesamt für
auswärtige Angelegenheiten dass
zentralisieren das stärker
digitalisieren das ist zwingende
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir schneller
werden und die Leute die wir haben
wollen ist denen auch leichter machen
diese diese ganzen extrem langsam und
bürokratischen Prozesse die sind halt
auch sehr viel missbrauchsanfälliger die
ziehen sich länger die Ver machen auf
allen Seiten Enttäuschung und es gibt
sie eben nicht nur migrationskontext
sondern das ist eben eine Ebene des
Vertrauensverlust wo ganz viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger einfach merken
wow der Staat ist gar nicht mehr
handlungsfähig die Art und Weise wie wir
das brauchen ja da bin ich da hinten wir
hinterher von der Regulierung
ich will nur einmal sagen dass also er
hat eine richtige Analyse aber es ist ja
nicht so dass wir nichts tun wenn ich
kann jetzt aus meinem Bereich berichten
ich bin ja nicht für alles zuständig ich
habe Bundesminister der Justiz z.B ist
dauert immer ewig lang manchmal
Gerichtstermine zu bekommen einfach weil
alle nicht können wir sorgen jetzt dafür
dass man das per Videokonferenz machen
kann das wird es sehr viel vielen Leuten
Reisezeiten reduzieren da werden wir
schneller reagieren können also wir
fangen jetzt an ich stehe ja im
Regelfall er in der Kritik weil ich zu
viel und zu schnell digitalisieren nicht
weil ich da so eine Abwehrhaltung hätte
also wir müssen den Staat durch
digitalisieren wir müssen ihn durch
beschleunigen und wir müssen die
Verfahren wie wir Gesetze machen in
Zukunft von digitalen Prozess herdenken
da arbeiten wir im Moment auch in meinem
Ministerium dann wir bauen da so eine
wirklich so eine Art kleine App die wir
für die anderen Ministerien einsetzen
können dass wir Gesetze so machen dass
man sie digital schneller und leichter
und damit im Regelfall immer auch
serviceorientierter vollziehen kann das
wird eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe sein
dass wir das hinbekommen
ja also ich höre immer wir wollen wir
wollen wir wollen also ich kann Ihnen
auch sagen wir wollen auch wir wollen
auch eine Menge bei der Bundespolizei im
digitalisierungsbereich sind wir
ziemlich weit hinten die Polizei an sich
ist ziemlich weit hinten im
digitalisierungsbereich und wenn ich den
Haushalt dann anschaue von der
Bundespolizei uns fehlen mindestens 360
Millionen im Haushalt 2024 um auf den
Stand zu bleiben wo wir jetzt sind nicht
mal drüber hinaus sondern wo wir jetzt
sind und dann höre ich immer nur wir
wollen wir wollen und die Bundespolizei
bekommt ja tausend schnell dazu Wahnsinn
für die tausend Stellen gibt es aber
dann vielleicht keine Ausrüstung dann
haben wir Verwaltungsleute mehr wir
müssten dieses Jahr 1,5% Verwaltung
einsparen ich kann doch nicht nur
Polizisten produzieren und habe nichts
mehr dahinter wir wollen Digitalisierung
genauso sorry und dann Gesetzes haben
Gesetzesvorhaben wir wollten das
bundespolizeigesetz Ändern derzeit liegt
es daran dass ihr Ministerium die scpo
ändern will im Bereich
Strafprozessordnung die
Strafprozessordnung ändern will und im
Bereich verdeckte Ermittler die wir auch
brauchen im Bereich organisierte
Kriminalität gerade da wo wir auch im
schleusungsbereich sind nämlich in der
organisierten Kriminalität kriegen wir
da irgendwie was nicht hin Herr
Buschmann so funktioniert das nicht
entweder wir machen jetzt bald das
Bundespolizei Gesetz ansonsten das ist
schon so alt das hat die letzte
Bundesregierung nicht hingekriegt mit
dem ehemaligen Innenminister aber wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine Erneuerung
dort und wir brauchen die neuen Sachen
da drin aber eventuell darüber sprechen
ja gar nicht will aber was soll ich
sagen wollte ist ich habe ja selber
einen Zuständigkeitsbereich und ich
halte immer viel davon dass bevor man
sagt andere sollen was tun erstmal bei
sich selber anfängt und ich kann sagen
dass ich in meinem Zuständigkeitsbereich
dafür gesorgt habe dass wir bei keinem
einzigen Digitalisierungsprojekt obwohl
ich auch sparen musste bei keinem
einzigen Digitalisierungsprojekt
irgendein Abstrich gemacht haben sondern
dass ich weiter daran arbeite dass
Prozessrecht so zu verändern dass wir
digitaler werden das heißt in meinem
Zuständigkeitsbereich will ich nicht nur
ich mache auch das kann ich auch belegen
und deshalb habe ich ja vorhin so ein
bisschen frotzlich gesagt ich wäre wäre
er dafür kritisiert dass ich zu viel und
zu schnell digitalisiere ich kann ihren
Ärger verstehen was das Bundespolizei
Gesetz eingeht nur ganz ehrlich das
liegt ja jetzt nicht nur an mir es gibt
beim Bundespolizei gesetzt eine ganze
Reihe von Dingen die kritisiert wurden
sind beispielsweise gar nicht von
unserem Haus es gibt zum Beispiel eine
also
eine Regierungsfraktion die die Sorge
hatte dass zu wenig gegen Rachel
Profiling getan wird und so weil es gibt
ganz viele Baustellen wo an dem Bundes
Polizei gesetzt rumdiskutiert wurde es
liegt nicht daran dass ich gesagt hätte
ich will dort keine Änderung im
Gegenteil ich wünsche mir sogar eine
schnelle Änderung und ich wünsche mir
eine abgestimmte Regelung was diese
verdeckten Ermittler angeht war ganz
ehrlich da kann man über Details immer
sprechen aber wir haben ganz verheerende
Ergebnisse in Untersuchungsausschüssen
gehabt da gab es ganz schlimme Exzesse
was in dem Bereich passiert ist und auch
erfahrene Polizisten sagen mir dass man
diese Exzesse beseitigen muss und
deshalb gibt es gute Gründe für die
Debatte aber ich bin ganz bei Ihnen das
muss man nicht ewig wie Kaugummi in die
Länge ziehen ich habe meine Vorschläge
schon vor vielen Monaten auf dem Tisch
gelegt ich bin auch kompromissbereit und
deshalb glaube ich liegt jetzt nicht am
Bundesministerium der Justiz dass die
Dinge nicht vorankommen sondern im
Gegenteil wir sagen immer sehr genau was
wir wollen wir machen Lösungsvorschläge
und wenn man sich dann die Hand gibt
oder
so können wir es nicht machen wir würden
es in der Variante machen dann können
wir auch Lösungsvorschläge finden aber
es ist nicht so dass wir da sitzen und
alles blockieren wenn wir werden ja
verrückt darf ich zum Schluss noch eine
Frage stellen muss man weil sie mich
auch
ein Vertreter der Regierung hier haben
wirklich interessiert gibt in Italien
große Kritik daran also dass wir über
diese Migrationsfrage streiten dass wir
der schieren zahlt nicht mehr Herr
werden und gleichzeitig werden sozusagen
über NGOs Betrieben
Menschen die sich auf den Weg machen mit
Hilfe deutscher NGOs auf Schiffen übers
Mittelmeer nach Deutschland geschafft
und der deutsche Steuerzahler zahlt auch
noch mit dafür das heißt wie finanzieren
diese NGOs diese Schiffe finanzieren wir
mit ja das ist keine Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung gewesen sondern dass ein
entscheidungsparlament gewesen weil sie
gesagt haben wir haben ja einen
Vertreter der Bundesregierung ja aber
auch als Parlamentarier interessiert
mich das also ganz Grund sehr wie sie
ihre Haltung dazu sollten wir diese
Praxis abschaffen oder sollten wir das
weiterhin so machen ist ja auch etwas
von diesen vielen widersprüchlichen
Dingen die man einen normalen Menschen
kaum noch erklärt bekommt also
einerseits sagen wir müssen diese Zahl
in Griff kriegen auf der anderen Seite
finanzieren wir sozusagen die Schiffe
die dann Menschen
von der nordafrikanischen Küste entweder
nach Italien fahren oder aus dem
Mittelmeer holen wo ich immer sagen
würde es ist richtig das zu tun aber wir
sind damit natürlich auch gleichzeitig
an Signal also ähm es ist so erstmal ich
habe ganz viel Verständnis dafür dass
Menschen sagen wir wollen nicht zusehen
wie wie Menschen sie helfen weil ich
glaube sie sind ja in ihrer Freizeit
helfen da ja auch mit andererseits bin
ich der Meinung dass das eigentlich
etwas ist was man staatlich organisieren
sollte also wenn wir wissen dass
Menschen sterben
dann muss man eigentlich das anders
organisieren und ich persönlich wenn ich
es alleine entscheiden würde würde
deshalb nicht auf diese Strukturen
zurückgreifen aber es ist für ein
Bundesminister ein wäre es ein bisschen
unanständig wenn ich eine Entscheidung
des parlamentsse kritisieren würde aber
wir schauen Sie darauf
es gibt ja in der Diskussion zwei
Ansichten die eine ist die dass die NGOs
losfahren von den schleuserbooten die
Leute übergeben bekommen oder
zurückfahren der nächste Ladung holen
und die ausbringend
ständig formuliert hat und aus dem sich
auch unglaublich viel wutscht sich
unheimlich viel los und wir müssen damit
umgehen Wut völlig zu Recht denn die
andere Sache sind die tatsächlich im
Mittelmeer schwimmende Schiffbrücke
aufsammeln Ja Gottes
wesentlich mehr Menschen ertrunken 2015
der scheint aber komplett aus dem Fokus
zu geraten also diese Arbeit sind ja
völlig richtig wenn die mit finanziert
wird von uns finde völlig richtig aber
natürlich den Schleusen die wenn das
tatsächlich so zutrifft die kann sie
nicht überprüfen stimmt so stimmt nicht
überhaupt mehr Erkenntnis
diese Geschichte weiß ich so auch nicht
ich kann das Handy auch nur aus der
Presse der Zeit die war aber
2015/2016 die gleiche Presse schon also
von daher wenn man Menschenleben retten
kann sollte man das tun was anderes
würde ich jetzt gar nicht sagen wollen
übernehmen und die Schleusen was ist
denn die Alternative sollen die NGOs
warten bis die Schleuser das sind
schlimme Menschen die einfach ins Meer
werfen und dann erst retten das ist ja
das will ja kein sehr hypothetische
Frage aber ganz umschrieben hat wäre
wenn es denn so war wäre ja auch ein
Straftat bestand also weil Schleuse ist
ja nach
96,97 Aufenthaltsgesetz ein
Straftatbestand und wenn ich tatsächlich
einen gemeinsamen Plan mit Schleusern
entwickle mit den arbeitsteilig
zusammenarbeite dann mache ich mich
natürlich auch
strafbar und deshalb muss man vorsichtig
sein mit diesen Geschichten muss man
dann aufklären das muss man ermitteln
aber in der Tat wenn es so wäre dass
Leute sagen wir sind humanitär unterwegs
in Wahrheit aber kollosiv mit
kriminellen zusammenwirken um
möglicherweise eine kriminelle auch
einträgliche Aktivität damit zu
unterstützen das kann natürlich nicht in
Ordnung sein ich sage das nur deshalb so
vorsichtig weil mir diese Erkenntnisse
also amtliche jedenfalls nicht vorliegen
aber darum muss man sich natürlich um
die Aufklärung kümmern und dann kommt
man ganz einfach an den Anfang wieder
zurück was Herr Buschmann sagte dann
muss man eben gucken wie kann ich das
stoppen das kann ich vielleicht in dem
Sinne stoppen indem ich vielleicht in
den afrikanischen Staaten
Zentren baue wo man dann eben auch Asyl
beantragen kann anders ist es ja im
Moment auch möglich irgendwie nach
Deutschland zu kommen vielleicht auch
mal mit UNHCR noch mal unsere
flüchtlingsbereich im im Bereich der UN
noch mal sprechen und da irgendwas
entwickeln und nicht immer sagen ja die
kommen jetzt hier hin sondern da muss
man Wege finden dass sie kommen können
legale Wege nach Deutschland und dann
würde er ein Schub von werden aber das
ist eben das große Problem was wir
derzeit auch ja Europa haben ich würde
sagen das gilt für diejenigen die eine
Qualifikation haben dass sie auch eine
Perspektive bei uns haben oder eben ein
Rechtsgrund haben es kann nicht einfach
so sein dass wir diejenigen die jetzt
illegal hier sind einfach legalisieren
das haben sie auch nicht gemeint dass
nicht nur sagen weil das immer wieder
auch in der Öffentlichkeit von der
rechten Seite auch so dargestellt wird
wenn man über solche Konzepte reden dass
man jetzt alle illegal legalisieren will
das will hier keiner sondern wir wollen
dafür sorgen dass Menschen die
Qualifikation haben die wir brauchen
gute vernünftige planbare Wege finden
darum kümmern wir uns jetzt dass Leute
die humanitäre Gründe haben vernünftig
versorgt werden können aber das und das
ist immerhin fast die Hälfte der
Menschen die nach Deutschland kommen die
kein Recht haben hier zu sein also
entweder nicht hinkommen oder aus dem
Land genau was heute jedenfalls klar
geworden ist wir müssen da irgendwie
Ordnung in dieses System kriegen